hello everybody my name is Nyan I'm a
black female engineer I provide content
for you and it's upon yourself for
engineers and today we are talking about
what I would do me if I needed to get a
job within the next one month yeah one
month and when I say a job I really mean
a developer role a software engineering
job when I really don't have that much
background experience either because I
self-taught I went to a boot camp any
reason at all I don't have much
experience and I needed a job yesterday
[Music]
right now today today today today I
would this day one out of 30. I would
update my resume the topic of resumes
can be so difficult for people because
as mentioned I'm gonna have previous in
this situation I don't have previous
experience in this role and so how in
the world do I set up my resume in a way
that attracts interviews and recruiters
see and say actually yeah this looks
like this could be a person for our team
let's bring them in let's talk to them
and eventually let's give them a job the
thing you want to focus on with your
resume is expressing all you have
learned throughout your transition to
becoming a software engineer and how you
would be a value add if you'd like to
better visualize really what I'm talking
about check out the link in my
description box I have a free resume
template up for you to use to yeah
create your resume because again I it
seems like you don't have much time and
you have no time to race so you can
check that out in the description box
below next thing we would do is focus on
optimizing our online presence and this
is more job related online platforms so
things like GitHub and Linkedin we need
to optimize our GitHub because if you
need a job within the next 30 days you
likely don't have the time to create a
whole portfolio site but you can house
your portfolio projects on GitHub if you
structure it a certain way if you'd like
to see how that's all done everything
like a really good detailed view of that
check out the video above I go into the
way I start shooting my own GitHub I
just needed something to get the job
done so I think this if you're like me
you just want to get the job done it'll
do what you're looking for but overall
you want your GitHub to clearly State
your different projects and so name your
repos
I talked about my project mints mints
front end then I have a men's web app
backend and in your readme's talk about
the project talk about the Technologies
used talk about the idea behind your
project and why why you decided to
develop it create it talk about the key
features of your web app and whatnot
really the same exact thing that is on
your resume do it again on GitHub in a
way that is easy to digest because that
can very very easily be where you host
your portfolio and that's where I was in
mind I I don't know creating a whole
portfolio site for my projects when
GitHub was right here that seems
ridiculous to me so I didn't do that so
do that and then with your LinkedIn
optimize your LinkedIn in a way that if
a person if a recruiter if a manager
went to your LinkedIn they would get
that same
everything now that I'm even talking
about it a lot of these things are
repetitive in that you just want to show
what type of professional you are what
you say on red on your resume you'll say
again on your GitHub which will say
again on your LinkedIn however
something's very specific to please
please please do on your LinkedIn is
right where it says uh your name and
then underneath it usually says the
person's occupation put software
engineer put
software
engineer I beg of you I went to a coding
boot camp and one of the things my
instructor said to me was
no one wants to hire an aspiring
software engineer
do you want to hire an aspiring doctor
do you want to hire an aspiring wealth
manager no you need to hire a software
engineer somebody who already claims it
and
of course so careers you can't do this
you aren't your doctor unless you have
the actual degrees and whatnot but
software engineering is a career that if
you can build you are a software
engineer you may be unemployed you may
be unemployed but you are still a
software engineer so put the words
software engineer right in your header
right in your um like where it says
occupation and whatnot and now in your
LinkedIn settings put your profile as
open to work
please please please please please do
this because recruiters actually use
this when they're trying to find people
to fill their roles and so by now you
positioning yourself as a software
engineer who is looking for a job makes
it so much easier for these companies to
find you but now that you've set up your
platforms and set up the different yeah
the different spaces you operate in as a
software engineer it is time to start
applying ideally this is day like three
it's time to start applying and so you
are looking up okay software engineering
roles in Miami you're looking at those
roles and you're scrolling through and
okay you're finding some that you like I
personally I used LinkedIn and Google
when looking for roles and I I think
it's just a preference thing and whatnot
I know people use indeed and whatnot I
focus Less on that
the platform doesn't necessarily matter
as much as long as they're reputable but
yes you're starting to see these jobs
come up again okay I want that one I
want that one I want that one I want
that one
that one's great
instead of just going in and applying
right away save the job ideally you have
a job application tracker if you don't
want to do all the work of setting it up
again because you don't have that much
time check the link in my description
box because I actually have a template
for a job application tracker that I use
and that you can use as well if you make
your own copy you can fill it out all on
your own but yes put these jobs all in
your job application tracker and then go
to LinkedIn and I know people are going
to like clock out when I say this
because it's so terrifying but yo we
need a job so like we we gotta we gotta
do some things that make us
uncomfortable go to LinkedIn and search
let's say the you found a job for I
don't even know it's Strava that's a fun
app right Strava you go to LinkedIn and
you search software engineer Strava and
see who pops up first round see if
there's any connections or almost
connections that fit you know software
Engineers travel likely there will not
be that was not the case for me but now
look through the profiles and see who
you think you can kind of easily strike
a conversation with so what does this
mean look for people that have
commonalities with you that you seem
similar to whether because of their
Identity or because of the previous work
they did or the things the organizations
are part of and whatnot you can kind of
easily see this through the people's
profiles me personally because there
aren't many black women in software
engineering whenever I saw a black woman
for the company I was looking up I would
immediately reach out to them and so I
would click connect and right when you
click connect you have an option to add
a message I would add a message and I
say like something like hi my name is
Naya I'm very interested in the software
developer role open at Strava
um being that there's not many black
women in this space I would really love
a 15-minute chat with you about your
experience within this company or within
this role at this company and yeah leave
it at that usually you I think you are
only allowed like 300 characters not
even words with characters so the
message has to be pretty short but yeah
then click Send wait like a day or two
and hope that they back out to you if
they do first message say I'm I'm free
these days for a 15 minute phone call
please let me know which days work for
you it is so much more valuable to get
these people on the phone because it
creates that deeper connection even if
it's just 15 minutes and there's a
saying in just LinkedIn and just job
hunting I guess in general which is ask
for a job and get advice ask for advice
and get a job and that's what we're
trying to do here we are trying to ask
all these people for advice what's your
experience working in this company do
you have any advice for me as I go
through the application process
um what things do you think I should
know as a person who's worked here x
amount of years so keep keep messaging
people if two days go by and you haven't
heard back from the people you reached
out to then go ahead and apply for the
job but hope that they'll reach out to
you later and you can get a conversation
going and the reason I say wait before
applying like wait to hear back from
them again no more than one or two days
don't you know risk your career for
waiting on these people but the reason I
say wait is because by you then saying
like you to talk for you know the 15
minutes then the next day or the next
hour messaging them again and taking
them for their time and being like I
have applied that lets them know like oh
okay if I look up right now the
applications that came through I'll
likely find this person and let you can
then let them do what they want with
that information with your application
really the goal being that they move it
forward to the hiring manager talk good
on you and you get an interview but yeah
again do not wait any longer than one to
two days one and a half days half day
you should be applying to jobs every
single day another thing you should be
doing every single day is practicing on
lead Code Practice data structures and
algorithms on Lee code because once you
get through the interview process and
once when you're going through the
interview process you will likely come a
time there will likely come a time where
you need to
complete a coding challenge or a pair
program or anything like that so it's
very very important that you get your
practice in I like lead code the reason
I like leeco so much is because I feel
like you get the most
for not spending anything there are
there are options to spend money and get
memberships with the code and you get
more out of it however for just a free
plan you get honestly everything you
need and so I really love the code for
that especially because of just as easy
to use and I like their design just
Sleek clean user-friendly design so
practice on the code every single day
definitely subscribe if you're not
already subscribed because later on I'm
going to do a video on how specifically
I used Lee code in order to get me ready
for these Tech interviews but yes
practice practice practice at least at
least two problems a day please please
please do that so those are the things
you should do daily now on a semi-weekly
basis you should be posting on LinkedIn
it's not enough that you have a picture
up and you set yourself as software
engineer and open to work you need to be
an active participant in the community
and what that may look like is posting
about the projects you've created
posting like walkthrough videos of the
projects you created write articles
coding articles post them to medium
nothing it doesn't have to be anything
crazy just top five things I learned
about JavaScript with so and so cores
just talk about kind of like be a
content creator for that time that
you're looking for a job and repost it
on LinkedIn be an active participant you
don't know which keywords in which post
that is going to catch the right
person's eye and get you to that next
level again I know it's annoying people
hate this part but look it in this
economy no we got to do what we need to
do to get the job another hard thing
people don't like to do
Network I know I know about half of you
just dropped off the second I said that
word that that bad word however because
I also am an introvert so I have found
ways to do so without me
for virtual networking I recommend going
to Facebook and searching for software
developer groups and so searching like
if you're a woman say woman software
engineer or women in Tech and if you're
a person in a minority group saying like
people of color in Tech or Hispanics in
Tech black people in Tech black software
Engineers X Y and Z get part of those
groups because those people a lot of
them are people with jobs looking to pay
it forward and you want to yeah Network
and get people to know you and to talk
to people get virtual coffee chats and
when it comes time for a new job to be
filled that you can very easily point to
you because you have already made
yourself know done your rounds and it's
clear that you could be the right person
for this job I'm gonna add one of the
groups I'm in it's phenomenal it's run
by this man named Esco and it is
phenomenal it's like oh my gosh I love
it so much everyone is so active so
helpful people give each other referrals
like even without knowing each other
because yeah it's just we want we want
to help and we want to bring people up
so I'll add the link in my description
box below and just like what you're what
I said to do on LinkedIn like be active
be very active on these Facebook pages
or slack Pages or whatever page you
found like people's stuff comment on
people's stuff ask questions yourself
you really want to be like hey
here I am and I'm not playing around and
then finally do not think that following
up on your applications won't do
anything Things fall through the crack
and by following up it not only assures
you of this company's decisions but it
also makes it clear to them that hey
this person really wants to stop this so
really really there's just no real
downside of reaching back out following
up and saying like hey what happened
with my application like I would I would
like to know but yeah there we go
everybody everything I would do if I
needed a job in one month let me know
what questions you have so look out for
those follow-up videos where I do go
more even just granular on
hope this was helpful let me know if it
was and I'll talk to you later bye